Salut ! Avant de vous donner l'énigme du jour, je vous donne la réponse de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, regardez là puisque là dans quelques secondes je vais vous donner la réponse.
Et donc vous n'aurez plus le plaisir de la résoudre, puisque vous connaitrez déjà la réponse.
Et la réponse à la question, c'est simplement que Claude est une femme.
Donc forcément ce n'est pas le frère de Franck
mais simplement sa sœur !
Et maintenant l'énigme !
Enigme numéro 4 et énigme un petit peu plus difficile. On va dire 4 sur 5 en difficulté.
Imaginez que vous arrivez devant un grand trésor !
Oh !!!
Sauf qu'au lieu d'être une pomme ce serait un diamant !
Mais devant ce trésor, il y a un génie qui barre la route. Il est comme ça.
Et pour passer il faut réussir à poser une question au génie, mais une question à laquelle il sera incapable de répondre.
Mais le problème c'est que ce génie là sait tout. Il sait TOUT !
Il a toute la culture, toutes les connaissances possibles, il sait tout !
Et il a la qualité de son défaut, c'est qu'il ne peut pas mentir.
Donc le génie doit toujours dire la vérité, il sait tout et pourtant vous devez lui poser une question à laquelle il sera incapable de répondre.
Elle est plus compliquée cette énigme, c'est clair, mais dans ces cas là, trouver la réponse est encore plus intéressant !
Si vous la trouvez, mettez dans les commentaires que vous avez trouvé, mais ne dévoilez surtout pas la réponse.
Mettez également un pouce en l'air dès que vous avez trouvé la réponse.
Il y aura moins de pouces en l'air, je pense, sur celle-ci, puisqu'elle est plus compliquée, mais encore une fois ça nous permettra de voir
quel est le nombre de personnes qui a trouvé la bonne réponse, par rapport au nombre de vues.
Profitez encore et toujours du soleil !
J'espère qu'il fait beau là où vous êtes !
Passez un bel été !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine et de partager cette vidéo, parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an !
Là on est sur la série d'été, un peu plus tranquille.
Rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !